so so devil's advocate here I I'm not I  wouldn't probably approach it like that  but like back in the day didn't women  drop the handkerchief  right right women dropped the  handkerchief but that's but you see the  thing is right is that years ago you  dropped a handkerchief and the man  showed you was interested you didn't  drop your knickers  and that's the difference drop in a  handkerchief is totally different from  dropping your knickers  they used to drop a hat you know you  walk along and you drop a hanky just to  see whether or not the man was  interested  but now the women are dropping their  knickers to see whether the man's  interest no I don't